.
* Grunzen *
* Düstere, dröhnende Klänge *
Wir sind hier im Deckzentrum.
Heute werden wir
14 Schweine belegen.
Belegen heisst, dass wir
eine künstliche Besamung vornehmen.
Dieser Blister hier
enthält verdünntes Eber-Sperma.
* Grunzen und Quieken,
dumpfe Klänge *
Fünfmal mehr Schweine als Menschen.
Willkommen in Hohenrain,
im Luzerner Seetal.
Damit es etwas besser flutscht.
* Blubbern *
Und ...
... nun stülpe ich es darüber
und fixiere es sauber,
damit es nicht zurückrutscht,
und befestige es am Besamungsbügel.
Meine Arbeit ist getan.
Den Rest macht die Sau selbst.
Es ist eigentlich nichts anderes
als eine Lungenmaschine.
Man pumpt Sauerstoff rein,
wo er fehlt.
Kann man von künstlicher
Beatmung sprechen?- Genau.
* Blubbern *
Und wenn Sie das nicht tun würden?
Dann würde der See
wieder kaputtgehen.
* Dunkle, spannungsvolle Klänge *
Denkst du, die Sau fühlt sich wohl?
Es hat sich noch nie eine beschwert.
* Dunkle, spannungsvolle Klänge *
2265.
(Mann) 2265.
Haben sie keine Namen,
z.B. Rosa wie bei Kühen?
Bei so vielen Tieren wäre es schwie-
rig, jedem einen Namen zu geben.
Massenproduktion -
und massenhaft Gülle.
* Bedrohliche Klänge *
Seit wie vielen Jahren ist der
Baldeggersee auf der Intensivstation?
Seit 40 Jahren.
Es wird einfach zu viel gegüllt.
Es ist wirklich extrem.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
* Grunzen,
dunkle, bedrohliche Klänge *
* Blubbern *
* Grunzen *
Jetzt, jawohl. Jetzt sieht man
schon das Schwänzchen.
Und hier ist es - ein schön Grosses.
Ein richtiger Brocken.
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge, Grunzen *
Du hast ein bisschen
viel Fruchtwasser geschluckt, was?
Willst du schon abhauen?
Du hast noch keine Ferien.
Nein, nein, nein.
Du bist ein Frechdachs, komm.
So.
* Ruhige Musik *
Turi Röösli: ein typischer
Schweinezüchter im Luzerner Seetal.
140 Sauen. Ihr Produktionswert:
rund 4'000 Ferkel pro Jahr.
Das ist enorm.
Ja, das ist
ein ziemlicher Zuchtfortschritt.
In den letzten zwei, drei
Jahrzehnten hat sich einiges getan.
Aber nicht alle Ferkel
überleben die Geburt.
Jetzt sind etwa 130 Fr. gestorben.
Für dich fällt es ins Gewicht,
wenn eines stirbt?
Ja, wir freuen uns nie, wenn
ein Ferkel stirbt, das ist klar.
Wir wollen natürlich möglichst
alle geworfenen Ferkel aufziehen
und später verkaufen.
Die fruchtbaren Muttertiere
können sehr lukrativ sein:
700'000 Fr. Umsatz
macht er in guten Jahren
und 150'000 Fr. Gewinn vor Steuern.
In schlechten Jahren aber
halbiere sich der Gewinn, sagt er,
weil der Schweinepreis schwankt.
Welche Nummer ist das jetzt?
- 6'003.
Wie lange dauert
das Leben eines solchen Ferkels?
Sein Leben wird nach
einem guten halben Jahr beendet.
Das ist leider sein Schicksal.
* Ruhige, nachdenkliche Musik *
In der freien Natur
würde 6'003 rund zehn Jahre alt.
Sein kurzes Leben
wollen wir dokumentieren.
Die Kehrseite unseres Hungers
nach günstigem Fleisch:
viele Tiere, viel Mist.
Mit der Gülle von Turis Schweinen
könnte man rund 78 Lastwagen füllen -
jährlich.
Wertvoller Dünger für Ackerpflanzen -
in der Masse aber schädlich für
einen See wie hier den Baldeggersee.
* Trommelnde, bedrohliche Klänge *
Das sind offensichtlich
aufgerahmte Blaualgen.
Das ist auch ein Zeichen
für die Überdüngung des Sees.
Ein solcher Algenschleim am Ufer
sollte nicht vorhanden sein.
Das ist eine ziemliche Schweinerei.
Die Tiermast ist am falschen Ort.
Wenn man in der Schweiz
intensiv Tiermast betreiben will,
darf das nicht im Einzugsgebiet
sensitiver Seen geschehen.
Entschuldigung, das ist einfach so.
Das ist ein wissenschaftlicher Fakt.
* Unstete, elektronische Musik *
* Blubbern *
So sah der Seegrund
in den 1980er-Jahren aus:
eine tote Mondlandschaft.
Überdüngt durch Abwässer
aus Haushalten und der Industrie
und durch Gülle.
Seit aber Kläranlagen gebaut
und Phosphat im Waschmittel
verboten wurde,
ist die Gülle hauptverantwortlich
für die Überdüngung -
seit Mitte der 1980er-Jahre.
Früher güllten wir mit Schläuchen,
von Hand.
Hast du früher Dinge getan,
die du heute nicht mehr tun darfst?
Früher güllte man auf den Schnee.
Das darf man heute nicht mehr.
Schmilzt der Schnee, fliesst
ein Teil der Gülle in den See.
Klärschlamm
war natürlich auch noch im Einsatz.
Ja, Klärschlamm gab es auch,
aber nur zwei oder drei Jahre lang.
* Dunkle, bedrohliche Klänge *
Wieso war das nicht gut?
- Das weiss ich nicht mehr genau.
Weil man ihn nun verbrennt?
- Wegen der Schwermetalle?
Ich weiss es nicht genau.
Das war vor meiner Zeit.
Später wurde es verboten.
* Dröhnende, bedrohliche Klänge *
1984 - der Tiefpunkt
im benachbarten Sempachersee:
Rund 300'000 Fische starben.
Auch im Baldeggersee gab es
ein grosses Fischsterben 1978.
Dann begann man,
Sauerstoff hineinzupumpen,
damit es zuunterst im Grundwasser
Sauerstoff gibt
und dort wieder Tiere leben können.
Es wurden tonnenweise
tote Fische herausgefischt.
Ab einer Tiefe von 10 m
war das Wasser tot.
Ich ging jeweils im See schwimmen,
aber später tat ich das wegen
der vielen toten Fische nicht mehr.
Wie war es für Sie, das zu sehen?
- Hart.
Wir hatten schon den Verdacht,
dass es teils daran liegen könnte.
An der Gülle?
Aber zu 100 % beweisen
konnten sie es ja nicht.
Sie mussten zuerst herausfinden,
woran es liegt.
Hattest du ein schlechtes Gewissen?
Nein, niemand hatte
ein schlechtes Gewissen.
Es war ja nicht meine Idee,
sondern die der Politiker.
* Dunkle, spannungsvolle Klänge *
Heute sind die Bauern
beim Baldeggersee gezwungen,
weniger Gülle auszubringen.
Aber jeder neue Tropfen
ist ein Problem -
wegen dem Güllen-Nährstoff Phosphor.
Die meisten Böden um den See
sind vom massiven Güllen von früher
übersättigt mit Phosphor.
Wenn es nach dem Güllen regnet,
gelangt der Phosphor
v.a. über unterirdische Rohre,
sog. Drainagen, in den Baldeggersee.
* Unstete, elektronische Musik *
Der gelöste Phosphor düngt den See:
Algen wachsen und vermehren sich.
Sie sterben aber schnell
und werden von Bakterien abgebaut.
Dieser Prozess
braucht viel Sauerstoff,
der den Lebewesen im See fehlt.
Darum muss der Baldeggersee seit
40 Jahren künstlich beatmet werden.
Und selbst das ist zu wenig
für die wichtigste Fischsorte.
Der Felchenbestand
ist massiv gesunken.
Heute gibt es viel weniger Felchen,
aber immer noch mehr als damals,
als der See tot war.
Um wie viel ist der Bestand gesunken?
Bestimmt um 50 % oder mehr.
Überleben Felchen im Baldeggersee
auf natürliche Weise?
Können sie sich vermehren?
- Nein, das geht nicht.
Sie können sich nicht vermehren.
Die Felchen müssen
künstlich befruchtet werden.
Sie vermehren sich am Seegrund,
und dort hat es trotz Belüftung
zu wenig Sauerstoff.
Täte man das nicht,
hätten sie keine Chance.
Dann gäbe es hier
gar keine Felchen mehr?- Nein.
Das macht einem
manchmal schon ein bisschen Angst.
* Dröhnende, bedrohliche Klänge *
Wir arbeiten mit der Natur.
Die Natur ist unsere Produzent,
den wir bewirtschaften.
Daher finde ich, dass ihr - wenn
auch aus wirtschaftlichen Gründen -
eure Grundlage zerstört.
Ich weiss nicht,
inwiefern der Baldeggersee
unsere Grundlage sein soll.
Dort muss man ...
- Biodiversität.
Biodiversität haben wir
auf all unseren Feldern.
Ich erfülle die Vorgaben.
Ich frage mich, ob die Belüftung
der richtige Ansatz ist,
wenn es nach 40 Jahren
nicht besser geworden ist.
Die Belüftung
ist nur eine Symptombekämpfung.
Das sagte der Professor der
Gewässerchemie schon vor 30 Jahren.
Eine technische Sanierung
dieser Seen ist nicht möglich.
Die Sanierung der Seen
muss im Einzugsgebiet beginnen.
Angenommen, die Bauern hier
würden ab morgen nicht mehr güllen -
wie lange würde es dauern, bis man
die Seebelüftung abschalten könnte?
Wenn man es
wirklich clever machen würde,
würde es mehr als zehn Jahre dauern.
Wenn man es etwas halbherzig angeht,
dauert es wohl 20-30 Jahre.
Und so ist es jetzt?
Nein, so wie man jetzt vorgeht ...
... ist es fast unabsehbar,
wie lange es dauert.
Ja ...
Wenn das die Erklärung
der Wissenschaft wäre,
hätten sie uns
schon lange den Hahn zugedreht,
damit wir
gar nicht mehr güllen können.
Aber das tun sie nicht, weil dann
die Landwirtschaft zusammenbräche.
Die Landwirtschaftslobby ist stark.
- Das hat nicht nur damit zu tun.
Das hat mit der gesamten
wirtschaftlichen Produktion
vor, mit und nach der Landwirtschaft
zu tun.
Rund um die Mittellandseen
ist die Zahl der Schweine
nach 1960 explodiert.
Ein Schweinevalley entstand:
mit Metzgereien,
Futtermühlen, Stallbauern,
Schweine- und Gülletransporteuren.
Jährlicher Umsatz:
schätzungsweise fast 1 Mrd.
Rund 3'500 Arbeitsplätze.
Wirtschaftlicher Erfolg
auf Kosten der Umwelt:
Seit 40 Jahren müssen
drei Seen künstlich belüftet werden:
Rund 130 Steuermillionen
kostete die Seesanierung bis heute.
Und v.a. beim Baldeggersee
ist kein Ende in Sicht.
Ich bin ja auch ein Steuerzahler
und möchte nicht,
dass eine Landwirtschaft
subventioniert wird,
die die Umwelt zerstört.
Im Einzugsgebiet des Baldeggersees
dürften höchstens halb so viele
Tiere gehalten werden wie jetzt.
Das weiss man seit sehr langer Zeit
und trotzdem ...
Seit wie lange?
- Seit 30 Jahren.
Das wurde auch
mit dem Kanton besprochen.
Was sagte denn der Kanton?
- Der Kanton ist nicht der Kanton.
Es gibt ein Umweltamt
und ein Landwirtschaftsamt.
Im Kanton Luzern ist es so, dass
das Landwirtschaftsamt bestimmt,
was in der Landwirtschaft passiert.
Das Umweltamt ist die Nr. 2.
* Düstere, bedrohliche Klänge *
* Knarren und Quietschen *
Tatsächlich: In einem
internen Protokoll des Kantons
aus dem Jahr 2000 steht:
Man kann zwar Gesetze kreieren,
aber die Durchsetzung
steht auf einem anderen Blatt.
Werden Bauern, die illegal arbeiten,
nicht gleich behandelt
wie Verkehrssünder?
Nicht ganz.
Die Umweltschutzvorschriften
sind ja nie so scharf,
dass man sagen kann:
"Er fuhr etwas schneller als erlaubt
und erhält nun eine Busse."
Es ist möglich, dass wir von einer
Tierbestandsreduktion sprechen.
Wir sind aber ...
- Dieses Eisen wollen Sie anpacken?
Ja, wir werden unser Möglichstes
tun, um dieses Ziel zu erreichen,
aber das kann ich Ihnen
heute nicht versprechen.
Man benötigt halt
eine gewisse Geduld.
Man darf nichts überstürzen.
Man muss
Schritt für Schritt vorgehen.
Lieber kleine Schritte
als gar keine.
Der verantwortliche Regierungsrat
hat beide Ämter unter sich:
das Umwelt-
und das Landwirtschaftsamt.
Vor vier Jahren übernahm
Fabian Peter diesen Posten.
Als ich das Amt antrat,
zog ich einen Mediator bei.
Ich führte eine Mediation
mit den Umwelt- und
den Landwirtschaftsverbänden durch.
Das war nötig, weil das Ganze mit
so vielen Emotionen behaftet war.
So schaffte man es,
wieder miteinander zu reden.
Sie sind seit vier Jahren im Amt
und wissen,
dass Sie mit Ihrer Politik
gegen das Gewässerschutz verstossen.
Ich verstosse ja
nicht persönlich dagegen.
Letztlich ist es der Kanton Luzern,
der das Gesetz nicht einhalten kann.
Es besteht seit Längerem ein Problem
und man kann es
nicht per sofort lösen.
Warum entschädigt man die Hälfte
der Bauern rund um diese Seen nicht,
damit sie ganz damit aufhören -
so wie es die Gewässerforscher
schon vor 30 Jahren vorschlugen?
Das Thema der Enteignung,
den Menschen etwas wegzunehmen,
ist in der Schweiz
nichts Alltägliches.
Das wollen wir
auch nicht unbedingt tun.
* Ruhige Musik *
6'003, hier bist du. So.
Es ist ein Junge.
- Ein Junge?
Er ist jetzt vier Wochen alt
und wiegt etwa 8 kg.
Nun werden sie
von der Mutter getrennt
und der Ernst des Lebens beginnt.
Sie sind nun Teenies
und kommen in den Jagerstall.
* Schrilles Quieken *
Was hat es?
Es ist nicht gern bei mir.
Es will wieder runter.
Kannst du ihm
einen Charakter zuschreiben?
Spürst du etwas Individuelles?
Es ist auf jeden Fall
eine Wildsau.
Eine Milchsau?
- Eine Wildsau.
Ja, du. Ja, ja.
* Schrilles Quieken *
Komm.
Vor dem Stallwechsel
werden die Ferkel geimpft.
Das ist eine Sau
mit viel Mutterinstinkt.
Sie freut sich nicht,
wenn wir ihr ihre Jungen wegnehmen.
Das kann für uns als Tierbetreuer
manchmal sehr prekär werden.
Es kann sein, dass sie aggressiv
werden und uns sogar angreifen.
Ist es nicht unnatürlich,
ihr ihre Kinder wegzunehmen?
* Lautes Grunzen *
Ja ...
Irgendwann
muss man sie ihr wegnehmen,
sonst kann man das Tier
nicht mehr zur Zucht verwenden.
Bei uns geschieht das
innerhalb von vier bis fünf Wochen.
* Schrilles Quieken *
In der Natur bleiben die Ferkel
rund drei Monate bei ihrer Mutter,
also rund dreimal länger.
Natürlich gehen wir
in solchen Haltungssystemen
immer Kompromisse ein.
In der Natur würde man ihr
ihre Kinder nie wegnehmen.
Ja, sie würden länger
bei ihr bleiben, das ist klar,
aber wir sind hier
in einem Stallhaltungssystem.
Pass auf, Jurek.
* Schrilles Quieken *
He!
* Die Sau grunzt laut. *
* Das Ferkel quiekt schrill. *
Turi Rööslis Schweine
werden konventionell produziert.
Zwei Drittel unseres Schweinefleischs
werden so hergestellt.
Danach kommt sie wieder
ins Deckzentrum und wird gedeckt.
Eine solche Sau kann
acht- bis zehnmal Junge werfen,
bis sie den Betrieb verlässt und
durch ein neues Tier ersetzt wird.
Das ist der Kreislauf,
wie wir unseren Betrieb führen.
Ein Kritiker würde sagen, dass diese
Muttersau eine Gebärmaschine ist.
Dann soll sie der Kritiker
als Gebärmaschine bezeichnen.
Ich meine, dieses Tier
hat zwischen den Perioden,
in denen es trächtig ist,
115 Tage frei.
Wie ich zuvor schon sagte,
achten wir darauf,
dass es den Tieren in
unserem Betrieb möglichst gut geht.
Wenn bei uns in der Schweiz
eine Nachfrage
nach Schweinefleisch besteht,
produzieren wir Schweinefleisch.
* Schrilles Quieken *
Ja, ja. Komm.
* Unruhige Klänge *
Wie schweizerisch aber
ist Turis Schweinefleisch?
Die Schweiz
hat mehr Nutztiere als Ackerflächen,
um Futter für sie anzubauen.
Würden Schweine
nur mit Schweizer Futter ernährt,
gäbe es 60 % weniger Tiere.
Das besagt eine Studie
der Zürcher Hochschule
für Angewandte Wissenschaften.
6'003
und seine Kolleginnen und Kollegen
brauchen Kraftfutter zum Wachsen:
Weizen, Gerste und Soja.
Rund 60 % der Proteine für Schweine
werden importiert.
Endstation Basler Rheinhafen:
Die Futtermittelimporte haben sich
verdoppelt in den letzten 20 Jahren.
Futtersoja
wird v.a. in der EU angebaut,
aber fast 10 %
stammten letztes Jahr aus Brasilien
und rund 20 %
aus der Ukraine und Russland,
laut dem Soja Netzwerk Schweiz.
Die grösste Futtermühle der Schweiz
steht in Herzogenbuchsee.
Hier wird das importierte Futter
mit dem in der Schweiz angebauten
für Turi Röösli gemischt.
Für seine Schweine
braucht er 300 t jährlich -
im Wert von rund 200'000 Fr.
23 volle Lastwagenladungen pro Jahr.
* Grunzen *
Im Vergleich zur Ackerfläche
hat die Schweiz zu viele Nutztiere.
Um alle Tiere füttern zu können,
braucht es im Ausland
eine Anbaufläche
von der Grösse
des Kantons St. Gallen.
D.h.: Rund zwei Drittel der Fläche,
auf der Kraftfutter
für unsere Nutztiere angebaut wird,
liegt im Ausland -
laut der Studie der Zürcher Hoch-
schule für Angewandte Wissenschaften.
Ist das noch Schweizer Fleisch?
Meiner Meinung nach kann man
von Schweizer Fleisch sprechen,
wenn das Tier hier zur Welt kam
und hier produziert wurde.
Natürlich wird es nicht nur mit
Futter aus der Schweiz produziert.
Von meinem Futterlieferanten,
der UFA AG, weiss ich,
dass er sehr bemüht ist,
möglichst europäische Komponenten,
z.B. Donau Soja, zu verwenden,
aber teils ist es
einfach nicht erhältlich.
Dann wird es halt mit dem Schiff
nach Europa gebracht.
Ausser, man produziert
auch die Tiere dort und ...
Wir können ja alles auslagern.
Dann sind wir irgendwann
nur noch Landschaftspfleger.
Ja.
Mit dem Futter importiert Turi Röösli
auch Gülle und damit Phosphor.
Und zwar viel mehr,
als seine Felder brauchen.
Wir können nicht die ganze Gülle
auf unseren Feldern ausbringen.
Dann wäre
die Belastung viel zu hoch.
Die Hälfte seiner Gülle muss weg.
Ich führe 1'000 m3 Gülle ab.
Das sind ca. 50 Lastwagen.
Bis ins Aargauer Fricktal
wird seine Gülle transportiert,
50 km entfernt.
Zu Bauern, die keine Tiere halten.
Die Luzerner Bauern müssen über einen
Drittel ihrer Gülle exportieren -
bis in den Kanton Waadt.
Ist das nachhaltig?
Man spricht von Gülle-Tourismus.
Ich sage: Was ist nachhaltig?
Anstatt 140 Muttersauen könnte ich
nur noch 70 Muttersauen halten.
Dann müsste ich weniger Gülle
abführen, fast keine mehr,
und weniger Mischfutter einkaufen.
Aber letztlich
ist es auch ein Geschäft.
* Summender, bedrohlicher Klang *
Zurzeit ist der Import von
Futtermitteln der wichtigste Faktor,
der für einen schlechten Zustand
des Sees sorgt.
Mit den Futtermitteln importieren
wir eine Überdüngung der Gewässer.
Aber der Kanton sagt:
"Wir bringen die Gülle ja weg."
"Wo liegt also das Problem?"
Meiner Meinung nach
ist das grosse Problem,
dass wir keine Puffer mehr haben.
Das Risiko, dass der See
überdüngt wird, ist viel zu gross.
Von diesem ganzen Gülleumsatz
darf nur etwa 1 % des Phosphors
in einen See gelangen.
Das ist fast nicht zu schaffen.
Man kann es nicht so genau messen
und hat es nicht so genau im Griff.
Wenn es etwas mehr regnet,
ist es bereits zu viel.
Der Kanton Luzern
versucht es mit Anreizen:
Wer weniger güllt,
bekommt Subventionen.
Das Phosphorprojekt
beim Baldeggersee
gibt es seit über 20 Jahren.
Lange war es freiwillig.
Warum aber werden die Bauern
als Verursacher der Verschmutzung
belohnt?
Einige brauchen ein Zückerchen,
damit sie reagieren.
Turi Röösli will die Subventionen
aber gar nicht, denn:
Wer viel Gülle hat,
zahlt auch viel fürs Wegbringen.
Bis jetzt hat
das Phosphorprojekt am Baldeggersee
36 Mio. Steuergeld gekostet.
(Wehrli) Aber man sieht
keine Abnahme
und das wäre das Ziel gewesen.
Schlimmer noch:
22 Steuermillionen, also 60 %,
seien gar nicht in die Gesundung
des Sees investiert worden.
Anfangs
finanzierten die Phosphorprojekte
einen ganzen Katalog von Massnahmen:
u.a. Streifenfrässaat
zur Erosionsverminderung,
was nachweislich nichts bringt,
oder der Bau von Weihern,
Retentionsweihern,
die das gülleverseuchte Wasser
zurückhalten sollen.
Auch dort wiesen wir nach,
dass das nichts bringt.
Es war eine Subvention für die
Landwirtschaft, nicht für den See.
Und noch schlimmer:
Um den See sind die Tierbestände
in den letzten 20 Jahren
um über 70 % gewachsen,
während gleichzeitig
die Steuermillionen flossen.
Da geht mir der Hut hoch.
Ich kann es nicht anders sagen.
Das ist doch ... Das muss
das Landwirtschaftsamt wissen.
Ich hätte auch von meinen Kollegen
im Umweltamt erwartet,
dass sie auf die Barrikaden gehen,
damit das nicht passiert.
Das ist klares Politikversagen.
Ich glaube, damals war die Idee,
mit diesem Ressourcenprojekt
auf freiwilliger Basis
diejenigen zu belohnen,
die sich in Bezug
aufs Austragen von Phosphor
entsprechend
zurückhaltend verhalten.
Das Aufstockungsthema
ist in der Raumplanung geregelt.
Das wurde nicht angefasst.
Ich weiss nicht, welches damals
die Überlegungen waren.
Seit 2020,
seit dem letzten Phosphorprojekt,
wurde
das Aufstockungsverbot umgesetzt,
damit man
nicht mehr Tiere halten kann.
Aber selbst das findet man
in bäuerlichen Kreisen nicht toll.
Wir ziehen nun gegen die Bauern, die
dagegen sind, vors Bundesgericht.
Sie sagen,
dieses Verbot gehe bereits zu weit.
Die Umweltverbände sagen,
es gehe zu wenig weit.
Werden Sie nicht
zwischen den Fronten zerrissen?
Ja, zerrissen ...
Die Ansprüche sind sehr verschieden.
* Nachdenkliche, klirrende Klänge *
* Grunzen *
6'003 ist jetzt
zweieinhalb Monate alt
und wechselt in den Maststall.
Kommt, wir machen eine Prozession.
* Grunzen und Quieken *
Nicht dort nach hinten.
Du Schlawiner, du.
Du bist der Kleinste und Frechste.
Vorwärts, einsteigen, kommt.
* Nachdenkliche Klänge *
Nun haben wir 270 kg. Sie wiegen
im Schnitt also 30 kg: etwa 130 Fr.
Das ist kein Scheisshaus,
sondern eine Waage.
* Lachen *
* Lautes Einatmen *
Ich habe die Nase gestrichen voll.
Hier oben stinkt es einfach
nach wie vor ganz erheblich.
Wir sind seit drei Jahren
im Ressourcenprojekt Geruch
und ich stelle fest: Wir kommen
nicht weiter. Es bringt nichts.
In Hohenrain liegen die Wohnhäuser
zu nahe bei den Bauernhöfen.
Darum haben Bund und Kanton
hier das erste Schweizer
Geruchsprojekt gestartet.
* Dynamische, trommelnde Musik,
Grunzen *
Reto Berthel, pensionierter Jurist,
in einem "Reporter"-Film.
Hallo?
Vor einem Jahr besuchte er den Hof,
von dem seiner Meinung nach
die üblen Gerüche stammen.
Herr Anderhub?
- Ja.
Mein Name ist Berthel. Danke,
dass ich Ihren Hof besuchen darf.
Das Problem:
Schweine im Freien stinken mehr.
Tierwohl versus Gestank.
Hier hatten wir Festböden.
Im letzten Winter ersetzen wir sie
durch Vollspaltenböden ...- Ja.
... damit die Flüssigkeit
versickert.- Ja.
Walter Anderhubs kleiner Beitrag zum
Geruchsprojekt. Viel nützt es nicht.
Damit es weniger stinkt, müsste er
den Auslauf im Freien schliessen.
Das Tierwohl.- Wie viel
würde es kosten, ihn zu schliessen?
Ich weiss es nicht.
Vielleicht 300'000 Fr.
Man kann schon sagen,
man solle ihn überdachen.
Aber ob dann der Stall
noch funktioniert?
* Lautes Quieken *
Sind Sie nicht bereit,
das selbst zu finanzieren?
Heute und morgen nicht.
Solange man Sie nicht zwingt,
tun Sie es nicht?- Nein.
Gezwungen aber wird niemand.
Auch dieses Projekt ist freiwillig.
So wie es das Phosphorprojekt
20 Jahre lang war.
Das Budget diesmal:
1,2 Mio. Steuergeld.
An einer Sitzung
mit dem Gemeindepräsidenten
übte Reto Berthel scharfe Kritik.
Meiner Meinung nach
fehlt eine klare Zielvereinbarung.
Es fehlen ein klares Konzept,
Transparenz
und Professionalität.
Besten Dank,
das war eine geballte Ladung.
Wir versuchen nun - gemeinsam
und auf freiwilliger Basis -,
Lösungen zu finden
und Verbesserungen zu erzielen.
Die Freiwilligkeit
widerspricht aber dem Gesetz.
Der Gestank in Hohenrain
ist übermässig.
Darum müsste der Kanton die Bauern
zwingen, den Geruch zu vermindern.
Warum tut das
der Vorsteher des Umweltamts nicht?
Wenn man sich das Parlament
im Kanton anschaut, sieht man,
dass es eine sehr starke Lobby gibt.
Diese sagt natürlich auch ...
Die Bauernlobby?
- ... wo es langgeht.
Es ist einfach schwierig,
das umzusetzen.
Äh, ja.
- Das Gesetz?
Das Umweltgesetz.
- Der Vollzug, ja.
Hallo, Turi.
- Guten Morgen, Reto.
Die Freiwilligkeit
schafft Ungerechtigkeit:
Turi Röösli
hat nämlich als einziger Bauer
einen neuen Luftwäscher eingebaut.
Jetzt kannst du mir sagen,
wonach es hier drin riecht.
Ich stelle fest: Hier drin
riecht es nicht nach Schweinen.
Es ist ein bisschen feucht
und es riecht etwas nach Erde,
aber es ist sehr angenehm.
Wie Waldboden, nicht wahr?
- Ja, so in etwa.
250'00 Fr. habe er
für den Luftwäscher bezahlt.
Die Projektleitung hat ihm
50'000 als Beitrag versprochen.
Turi ärgerte sich,
dass seine Berufskollegen
keine neuen Luftwäscher kauften.
Er nahm an einer Sitzung
der Projektgruppe teil ...
Hallo.
... geleitet vom Gemeindepräsidenten.
Turi Röösli kritisierte, dass
dieser Bauer zu Beginn des Projekts
seinen Stall
ohne Bewilligung umgebaut
und den Gestank
sogar noch verschlimmert hatte.
Da musste ich doch sagen:
"Scheisse, Röösli."
"Bist du jetzt der Dorftrottel
hier in Hohenrain?"
Im Moment komme ich mir so vor.
Ich habe alles so umgesetzt,
wie es gewünscht war.
Aber es kann nicht angehen,
dass 200 m neben mir gewurstelt
wird, um es mal so auszudrücken.
* Trommelnde, spannungsvolle Klänge *
Das Projekt
hat viele Verantwortliche.
Die Suche
nach dem obersten Verantwortlichen
führt uns zum Luzerner
Bäuerinnen- und Bauernverband.
Die Bauernlobby schützt die Bauern.
Der bewacht Fuchs den Hühnerstall.
Das sehe ich nicht so.
Wir leiten dieses Projekt,
um eine Lösung zu finden.
Wir sind uns
der Problematik bewusst.
Aber bis jetzt sieht es danach aus,
dass man mit Freiwilligkeit
nie eine Lösung erzielen wird.
Dann kann man uns nicht vorwerfen,
es nicht versucht zu haben.
Nach der Ausstrahlung
des "Reporter"-Films:
Die Bevölkerung wird zum Stand
des Geruchsprojekts informiert.
Medien sind ausgeschlossen.
V.a. Bauern seien gekommen,
sagt Turi Röösli.
* Spannungsvolle Klänge *
Sie bezeichnen mich
nicht direkt als Nestbeschmutzer,
aber sie sagen, das gehöre
an die Gemeindeversammlung
und nicht ins Fernsehen.
Ich wurde massiv angegriffen.
Sie applaudierten richtig.
Ich bin erstaunt,
dass so viele Bauern hier sind.
Dürfen wir Ihnen eine Frage zu dieser
Veranstaltung stellen?- Nein, danke.
Ich spürte, dass sie es
unter Verschluss halten wollten.
Aber sie haben
dieses grosse Prestigeprojekt
ja öffentlich gemacht.
Sie wollten es gut darstellen.
"DOK"-Filme würden gut aussehen.
Tja, jetzt ist es halt
anders gekommen.
Aber sie sind selbst schuld.
* Spannungsvolle Klänge *
(Mann)
Möchten Sie etwas dazu sagen?
Dass du dich als Alt-Nationalrat
traust, so was zu sagen, Sepp.
Dass du als Alt-Nationalrat
der Mitte so was sagst.
Ja.
Das ist ...
... Josef Leu, Alt-Nationalrat
der Mitte, Hohenrain.
Nein, das ist eine Katastrophe.
* Grunzen *
6'003 ist jetzt eine Mastsau.
55 kg.
Gewichtszunahme pro Tag: fast 1 kg.
Sein kurzes Leben
wird jetzt noch 60 Tage dauern.
(Mann über Funk) Eine Stopfmutter.
Was für eine Stopfmutter?
Verdammt noch mal,
was ist jetzt wieder los? Hallo?
Die kann doch nicht
einfach verschwinden.- Wieso?
Die Schrau... Sie ist nicht mehr da.
Wo ist sie? Sie kann nicht
einfach verschwinden. Ich hole eine.
* Unruhige, elektronische Klänge *
Gut.
Du musst ihn langsam starten.
* Trommelnde, spannungsvolle Klänge *
* Knirschen und Krachen *
* Dunkle, bedrohliche Klänge *
Ich zeige Ihnen ein Beispiel
eines Borkenkäferschadens,
der mich sehr stark beschäftigt.
Hier sehen wir
die klassischen Muttergänge,
wo die Eiablage stattfindet.
Die jungen Larven verpuppen sich
und in etwa fünf bis acht Wochen
wird es eine
neue Borkenkäfergeneration geben.
In einem Baum
befinden sich x Tausend Käfer.
Die Käfer, die sich hier
zu entwickeln beginnen,
werden in zwei bis drei Wochen
ausfliegen
und den nächsten Baum befallen.
Schuld ist die Trockenheit
der letzten Jahre.
Die vermehrt trockenen Sommer
setzen unseren Waldbeständen
extrem stark zu.
Der Baum wird geschwächt.
Dadurch ist er so schwach,
dass ihn der Borkenkäfer, den wir
hier sehen, leicht töten kann.
Mir tut es weh,
wenn ein Baum stirbt,
der nicht zur Ernte vorgesehen war.
* Düstere Klänge *
* Knirschen und Krachen *
Aber die Fichte hat noch ein anderes
Problem, sagen diese Forscher.
Hast du die Brombeeren gesehen?
- Ja, ja.
Die Bodenversauerung
hat vielerorts zugenommen.- Ja.
Biologin Sabine Braun und ihr Kollege
messen, wie sauer der Waldboden ist.
Hier im luzernischen Beromünster
inmitten von Landwirtschaft
ist er sehr sauer.
Das liege
am Stickstoff aus der Gülle.
Es ist, als würde ...
... ein Mensch die ganze Zeit
nur Pommes frites essen.
Es ist
eine sehr einseitige Ernährung.
Das macht die Bäume krank.
- Und anfällig für Schädlinge.
Was sind in diesem Fall
die Pommes frites?
Der Stickstoff.
Von der Gülle?
- Ja.
Beim Ausbringen der Gülle
gelangt Stickstoff
in Form von Ammoniak in die Luft.
Das Gas wird über Luft und Regen
in den Wald getragen.
Es lässt den Boden versauern.
Die Nährstoffe Magnesium, Kalium
und Kalzium werden ausgewaschen.
Das Ammoniak schädigt
auch die Pilze an den Baumwurzeln,
die für die Aufnahme von Wasser
und Nährstoffen wichtig sind.
Der Baum wird krank
und anfälliger auf Trockenheit.
Der Borkenkäfer greift stärker an,
wenn die Bäume
durch Gülle geschwächt sind.
Die Gülle verstärkt
das Sterben der Fichten?- Ja.
Es ist deprimierend,
wenn man sieht, dass ...
Viele Wälder
haben wir jahrelang verfolgt
und nun sind sie einfach weg.
Das tut weh.
* Düsterer, summender Klang *
Letztes Jahr starben zehnmal mehr
Fichten als im langjährigen Mittel.
Die Waldflächen der Schweiz:
Fast 90 %
sind mit Stickstoff überdüngt.
Massiv überschritten sind die
Grenzwerte in den Kantonen Luzern,
St. Gallen, Thurgau und Fribourg.
70 % des Stickstoffs
stammen aus der Gülle.
Sabine Brauns Institut wird von
13 Kantonen und dem Bund finanziert.
Aufgrund ihrer Daten
sollte die Politik reagieren.
Stattdessen
gerät die Forschung unter Druck.
Zwei Kantone seien ausgestiegen.
Ich nenne jetzt keine Namen.
Wie ist das für Sie?
- Es ist bitter.
Denn es wird einfach ...
Man streicht die Forschung
und versucht, das Problem
auf diese Weise zu lösen.
Man steckt den Kopf in den Sand?
- Ja.
* Spannungsvolle Klänge *
Wie es den Wäldern genau geht,
weiss ich persönlich nicht.
Wir haben auch knapp 4 ha Wald.
Dort achten wir darauf,
die kranken Bäume zu entfernen.
Stellst du auch fest,
dass die Fichten absterben?
Ja, das kam
in den letzten Jahren auch vor.
Jetzt ist es wieder besser,
aber es hat wohl
mit unserem Wasserverbrauch zu tun.
Die Forscher sagen, es habe
mit dem Stickstoff, der Gülle zu tun.
Das hat bestimmt
auch einen Einfluss.
Deswegen versuchen wir,
die Stallabluft zu reinigen
und wir bringen die Gülle
mit einem Schleppschuh aus.
Mit dem Schleppschuh kann die Gülle
nahe beim Boden ausgebracht werden.
So gelangen rund 50 %
weniger Ammoniak in die Luft
als mit der alten Methode,
die die Gülle breit verspritzte.
* Düstere Klänge *
Der Schleppschlauch
wird aber erst nächstes Jahr
schweizweit obligatorisch,
obwohl Experten das schon
vor 20 Jahren gefordert hatten.
Wie beim Phosphor- und Geruchsprojekt
galt auch für Ammoniak jahrelang:
Mitmachen ist freiwillig.
Die meisten Kantone
hatten Subventionsprojekte
für den Schleppschlauch
und andere Massnahmen.
14 Jahre lang
wurden Subventionen ausgeschüttet -
rund 240 Steuermillionen.
Die Ammoniak-Emissionen
aber sanken kaum.
Sie sind immer noch 40 % zu hoch.
Pikant: Sogar das Bundesamt
für Landwirtschaft gab zu:
In meiner langen Berufskarriere
habe ich gelernt,
dass viele Umweltschutzgesetze
nicht so vollzogen werden,
wie es dem Volk, das darüber
abgestimmt hat, versprochen wurde.
Das ist ein krasses Beispiel dafür.
Die Technik des Schleppschlauchs
ist seit 30 Jahren bekannt.
Wieso wurde das
nicht schon viel früher gemacht
und zwar verpflichtend?
Das war z.T.
natürlich ein Investitionsthema.
Die Schleppschlauchanlagen
kosten etwas mehr.
Der Subventionsteil des Bundes
kam jedoch erst später.
Sonst hätte der Kanton das
separat subventionieren müssen,
was man nicht tat.
Warum wohl?
- Das kann ich nicht nachvollziehen.
Ich denke, das Kosten-Nutzen-
Verhältnis spielte eine Rolle.
Oder man tat es aus anderen Gründen
nicht. Ich weiss es nicht.
Turi Röösli macht,
was technisch möglich ist.
Würde es reichen, wenn alle Bauern
auf diesem Stand wären?
Das reicht nicht.
Wir importieren
immer noch sehr viel Stickstoff
in Form von Kraftfutter
aus dem Ausland.
Dieser Stickstoff bleibt im System.
Was müsste man tun?
- Die Viehbestände reduzieren.
Im Kanton Luzern
müssten es 40 % weniger Tiere sein.
Das hat die Hochschule
für Agrarwissenschaften berechnet.
Wenn Sie
eine Vorlage ausarbeiten würden,
um die Tierbestände
um 40 % zu reduzieren,
würden Sie dann
nochmals wiedergewählt?
Ja, das, äh ...
Jetzt sind, äh ...
Die Frage ist vielleicht
etwas zugespitzt gestellt.
Es geht ja
nicht nur um meine Wiederwahl,
sondern die Frage ist auch ...
Ist das mehrheitsfähig?
- Würde das im Parlament ...
Wenn Sie mich fragen,
ob das mehrheitsfähig ist,
würde ich nein sagen.
Sie würden also nicht
als Regierungsrat wiedergewählt?
Darum geht es nicht.
Wenn das Parlament diese Vorlage
ablehnt, ist sie passé.
Logischerweise würde man sich
über eine solche Vorlage enervieren.
* Grunzen und Quieken *
Unterdessen gehen die Streitereien im
freiwilligen Geruchsprojekt weiter.
Die Anwohner und Bauern wurden
aus der Arbeitsgruppe verabschiedet.
Das sei überflüssig.
Wir würden nicht mehr gebraucht.
Sie machten sowieso,
was sie wollten.
Ich arbeitete schon
in diversen Arbeitsgruppen mit,
aber das war
mit Abstand die schlechteste.
Irrtümlicherweise hat er
ein Mail der Projektleitung bekommen.
Es geht um Bewohner
einer anderen Gemeinde,
die sich auch
wegen dem Schweinegestank beklagen.
"Sie warten ab, was wir im Rahmen
des Projektes herausfinden,
und wenn sich dann
eine Übermässigkeit beweisen lässt,
funken sie uns rein
und machen eine Klage."
"Das möchten wir
aber nicht wirklich."
Ich verstehe das so, dass
man uns nicht unterstützen will,
sondern dass man schaut, was man mit
der Freiwilligkeit erreichen kann.
Wenn man mit der Freiwilligkeit
nicht weiterkommt,
wird die ganze Sache ad acta gelegt
und es geschieht nicht.
Das ist doch eine
behördliche Arbeitsverweigerung,
die mit Steuergeldern
finanziert wird.
Der Kanton schreibt,
das Projekt bleibe freiwillig
bis zum Abschluss in fünf Jahren.
D.h.: Luzern
vollzieht das Umweltschutzgesetz
auch beim Gestank in Hohenrain nicht.
Auch Turi Röösli ist
im Clinch mit der Projektleitung.
Im Juni fand eine Sitzung
vor dem Friedensrichter statt,
wegen seinem Luftwäscher:
Er hat nur 30'000 Fr.
ausbezahlt bekommen
statt wie versprochen 50'000.
Der Luzerner Bauernverband
wollte ihm die restlichen 20'000
erst nach Projektende
in fünf Jahren bezahlen.
Hallo, Schatz.
- Wo bist du?
Hier.
- Ich dachte, du kommst nicht mehr.
* Turi lacht. *
Das ist nicht lustig.
Doch, doch.
- Ich habe mir Sorgen gemacht.
Was war los?
Raphael Felder
vom Bauernverband sagte,
das sei ein Grund, weshalb sie
die 20'000 Fr. zurückhalten würden.
Ich hätte das Projekt
mit meinen Aussagen
im "Reporter"-Film torpediert.
Sie sprechen sogar davon,
dass ich die Mitwirkungspflicht
verwirkt hätte.
Ich?
Die Mitwirkungspflicht verwirkt?
Wer hat in Hohenrain etwas getan?
Mann, war ich wütend.
Das wäre ich an deiner Stelle
auch.- Ich war fuchsteufelswild.
Später schlägt der Bauernverband
Ratenzahlungen bis Ende 2026 vor.
Turi lehnt das ab.
Er will jetzt vor Gericht klagen -
trotz Bedenken der Friedensrichterin.
Das ziehe ich jetzt durch.
Da könnt ihr euch sicher sein.
Da fragte sie mich: "Was haben Sie
denn davon, Herr Röösli?"
Ich sagte:
"Ich komme zu meinem Recht."
"Und ich kann den Leuten zeigen,
wie man hier mit uns umspringt."
Da macht kein Bauer mehr
freiwillig mit.
Das werde ich
überall schonungslos aufzeigen.
Da können sie sich sicher sein.
Es ist mir scheissegal, wenn sie
mir drohen. Ich habe keine Angst.
* Spannungsvolle Klänge *
Der letzte Tag bei uns.
Kommt, aufstehen.
Ja, jetzt müsst ihr aufstehen
und dann einsteigen.
Ja, ja. Komm.
Ja. Danach könnt ihr nach draussen.
Wir sind so aufgewachsen.
Wir waren immer dabei -
ob bei Kühen oder bei Schweinen.
Sogar beim Schlachten?
- Ja, wir waren oft dabei.
Ich kann kein Blut sehen,
v.a. bei mir selbst nicht.
Deswegen bin ich bei der Operation
eines Tiers schon umgekippt.
Aber heutzutage ...
Man lernt, damit umzugehen.
Man wächst damit auf und lebt damit.
Heute oder morgen
kommen die nächsten zur Welt.
Die auch wieder sterben müssen.
- Ja.
* Düstere, bedrohliche Klänge *
* Düstere Klänge, Grunzen *
Denkst du, die Tiere spüren etwas?
Nein,
aber wenn einige noch oben sind,
wollen die anderen
zu ihren Kameraden zurück.
Aber ansonsten ...
Sie erkunden
zuerst mal die Umgebung.
Nein, das ist kein Problem.
Ich glaube nicht,
dass es ein Problem ist,
dass sie das Blut riechen.
Jetzt dusche ich sie ab,
damit sie den Strom gut leiten.
So.
Ich schneide das hier ab. Achtung.
Wir hoffen, dass es schmerzfrei ist.
Aber wie es für das Tier selbst
ist, wissen wir auch nicht.
Was im Kopf eines Tiers vorgeht?
- Ja.
Was uns das Recht gibt, es zu töten?
- Ja.- Ja.
Im Schnitt isst jede und jeder
fast 1 kg Fleisch pro Woche.
* Sanfte Klavierklänge,
Schneidegeräusch *
Um die Umwelt zu schonen,
müssten es 70 % weniger Fleisch sein.
Also höchstens
noch zwei Schweinesteaks pro Woche.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
Manuela Waldner - 2023